[Musik]
ich bin und visiert beim
panzergrenadierbataillon 35 in groß
mittel in der dritten kompanie
kaderpräsenzeinheiten und möchte euch
heute mittelmeer über unser arbeitstier
schützenpanzer ulan erzählen
vorweg vielleicht sieht man das ist ein
neuartiges dann system das so genannte
barracuda dann system was macht das was
tut es ist für die wärme signatur
schwerer zu erkennen weil es die wärme
absorbiert genauso wie für das radar
nicht so leicht zum reflektieren ist ja
ich nehme ich jetzt mit auf die seite
wir haben einmal darf der seite ganz
normal unsere schützen die jungs vor
dreck beziehungsweise verstarb oder
vorschuss auf die kälte schützen sollen
die barracuda system ist einen ganzen
spz angebracht und ganzen schützenpanzer
auf der seite da einmal sieht man ganz
gut ist lüfter für den getriebefan für
den motor drinnen da oben ja wenn man
das so sieht ist vom turm die 76 mm
mehrfach wurfanlage
mit der wir
weißem phosphor beziehungsweise neben
verschießen um uns in einer brenzligen
situation im gefecht einfach schneller
natürlich sehen zu können
dann weiter da sieht man ganz gut ist er
wohl mehr versteckt jetzt sieht man
unser unsere werkzeug ist dahinter in
der werkzeugkiste quasi dauer trainer
peter schanz zeug an kanten oben säge
etc alles was man halt so draußen
brauchen kann wenn man in wald und wiese
erlebt dann hinten nehme ich euch mit
haben auf der hinterseite da jetzt quasi
damit dass barracuda system wäre das
funktioniert nur im großen ganzen quasi
eine klimaanlage die den schützenpanzer
bisschen weiter unterkühlt von der
temperatur und und das ermöglicht dass
man im wald gerät schlecht bis gar nicht
erkannt wird
dann nehme ich auch immer hinten hinten
mit in den quasi in den heckbereich vom
schützenpanzer auf der linken seite hier
einen stufen dank wo man 816 liter
diesel methan und je nach gelände und je
nachdem wo wir uns mit der grenadiere
mit den kreativen bewegen quasi zwischen
450 und 550 kilometer reichweite und wir
haben zehn liter hubraum also ab was
aber das braucht man ich nehme jetzt mit
rein in den kampf
finden im kampf frauen quasi die heimat
der grenadiere links vorne haben wir den
platz vom fahrer von der innenseite und
dahinter uns den turm wo der kommandant
auf der linken seite und rechts der
rechtsschütze sitzt und herunten jetzt
die grenadiere quasi die heimat haben
wir sind mit einer stärke von eins zu
sechs hunden im kampf frauen und führen
von da quasi dann aufgesessen
beziehungsweise beim wechseln der kampf
weise das ist das was uns kreative
eigentlich ausmacht den abgesessenen
kampf in von touristisch werden mit
entweder ein maschinengewehr oder je
nach bedrohungssituation auch zusätzlich
noch ein panzer abwehr war
die infanterie versucht natürlich so
lange wie möglich an schützen wasser zu
bleiben um natürlich die beweglichkeit
und die feuerkraft der schützenpanzer
ulan so lange wie möglich auszunutzen
jetzt nehme ich euch mit auf die linke
seite von unserem schützenpanzer ulan
wir haben eine länge von sieben metern
und ein kampfgewicht von knapp 30 tonnen
bringen auf die ketten weil ich noch
sagen möchte werden auf der rechten
seite ebenfalls
greifbar ist vielleicht ein schwierig
vorzustellen ist sowas wie für euch für
eure autos daheim auch schneeketten
braucht man nur bei ganz schwierigen eis
und schnee bedingungen ich nehme euch
jetzt mit nach vorne und zeigt euch die
schützenpanzer mit seinem herzstück von
uns
wir sind jetzt herum und turm und ich
möchte euch die haupt bewaffnung und
schützenpanzer ulan vorstellen das ist
eine vollautomatisierte voll
stabilisierte 3 cm kanone mit der wir
viele flächen ziele auf bis zu 2 km
entfernung bekämpfen können
leicht gepanzerte ziele auf eine
entfernung bis zu 1500 meter entfernung
bekämpfen da das ist die munition die
momentan das ist jetzt so existiere
munition aber damit ich euch mal zeigen
kann wie unsere kanadischer quasi als
schauen wir haben drei munition das ist
einmal steht steht für mehr zeigt
munition einmal eine karriere munition
für genetische um gegen gepanzerte ziele
vorzugehen oder so wie man um fürs üben
zum scharfschießen tetra
munition die was dann glaube
ebenfalls einmal noch auf der seite ein
koaxialer maschinengewehr vom kaliber 7
62 mit der wir ziele bis zu einer
entfernung von 600 metern bekämpfen
können und ich zeige euch jetzt noch die
besatzungen von touren
einmal auf der rechten seite ist der
platz des rechts der bedient die waffe
und ist für den ganzen turm in wahrheit
verantwortlich auf der linken seite ist
der platz des kommandanten das ist mein
arbeitsplatz
ich führe die schützenpanzer und seine
besatzung und links auf der vorderen
seite aber den fahrer wollte er ist auch
ein oder wichtigsten da am board euronen
fahrer kommen nirgendwo hin
[Musik]
und wenn ihr das leben von acht toten
die am 8
[Musik]